um we were speaking of big stars so I
heard that you have a crush on Tom
Selleck which who doesn't yeah I love
Thompson I love him he's been on this
show like I love this movie yes no him
and this all of them in the movie yes
yeah then I can't remember her name the
redhead but I was just like I loved them
no I love that yeah and then how they
got together yes right yeah Tom
Selleck's so hot do you think it's the
stash like I don't know what it is I
think it's like the I think it's tall
dark handsome I think it's the stash and
[Laughter]
no he was here actually and I I kept my
cool and I tried to like be cool in
front of him but I'm with you I he has
been like a crush since I was a kid yeah
I'd be like shaking my water glad I
don't know but I'd be like oh so what
sometimes
casual that's so cool that he was here
though on this couch that's awesome
you're like here we go no I just thought
it was funny because most people don't
have I don't have that in common with
most people yeah and I love that you
love Thompson we should get matching
tattoos that's what I think too his face
um maybe not
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]